hello everybody
and a warm welcome to the uncle mine
world autumn session for the north
american
so i'm luca coyata head of medical
affairs for thermo fisher scientific
and once again given the unprecedented
time that we are still
living in we're meeting virtually
on behalf of my thermo fisher scientific
colleagues
i want to say that we're very happy to
offer you again
one more time after our uncle my word
spring session
another hopefully very interesting and
valuable agenda
so thank you all very much for joining
us
hope you have seen the welcome message
from our clinical sequencing division
president
gareth hampton uh gareth has condensed
all the passion that we have about
oncology testing
and he has also shared um some of our
future plan so if you didn't have the
opportunity yet
you can access gareth's video message at
any time from the lobby
having said that i'm very pleased to
moderate
uh today's live session and actually i'm
very much looking forward for a very
vibrant discussion as we had it in the
previous section
from the apj and the emea um
early this morning for me and also at
lunchtime for me
and we are very engaging q a and i hope
it's going to be the same
also this time we will have also for
this time
two blocks of live presentation divided
by breaks
um and uh i will notify you once we're
getting closer to the break so that you
have the opportunity to go
and visit uh our poster hall our
position oncology old there's a lot of
very uh
informative new posters a lot of data
that i hope you will find very useful
but now let me introduce you the first
two speakers for today
which are dr carmen plexa she's a
medical director
from the molecular oncology uh
diagnostic
laboratory at the u.s department of
veterans affairs
she will be talking about molecular
testing
of nose muscle and cancer and she will
be
sharing what is her experience in the
routine molecular testing scenario
and then we'll move forward with the
second presentation from dr megan lin
she's a director of metaphorology
at the university of pennsylvania and
she'll be uh sharing with us some more
data about the clinical impact of
next-generation sequencing testing
from an a methodologist perspective
right after that we will have our first
q a section but now
with no further delay let's please start
with the first
presentation looking forward to talk to
you after that
hello and welcome to the uncommand world
autumn virtual meetings i'm carmen
klitecka
medical director of the byzan 22
molecular diagnostics lab
at the los angeles va and today i will
be talking about
molecular testing and diagnosis of
non-small cell
lung cancer biopsies and how to overcome
some of the challenges that working with
these very small
specimens can present
um here are some disclosures
more specifically i will be going over
the clinical guidelines for molecular
testing of non-small cell lung cancer
specimens
guideline recommendations for biopsy
tissue stewardship
and conservation techniques that have
worked out well for us
also how ngs for molecular testing has
been helpful
for us at our institution
this is a chart from the most recent
nccn guidelines for non-small cell lung
cancer
showing the recommended biomarker
testing for
advanced or metastatic disease and also
links for treatment algorithms based on
the testing results
this chart looks pretty elaborate but
the main point
is that the nccn
recommends testing for egfr mutations
alk and roswan rearrangements buraf
mutations
met exon 14 skipping mutations
ret translocation and pdl1 expression
in addition can also test for entract
fusions
met amplification and her2 mutations
this may identify an oncogenic driver
for which a therapy or clinical trial
may be available
the college of american pathologists
the international association for the
study of lung cancer
and the association for molecular
pathology
2018 updated molecular testing guideline
recommends
testing for egfr alk in ros1
at an absolute minimum
and if an expanded panel such as
ngs is available then they recommend
additional testing
for um brass
matt rat her2 and k
ras as well the um
molecular biomarker testing allows for
the identification of mutations that can
be used for targeted therapy
and this list here from the nccn shows
several fda approved targeted therapy
drugs
for metastatic non-small cell lung
cancer
and this gives the oncologist more
options
to treat their patients with the ability
to apply
precision oncology
so for the biopsy
our clinical colleagues go through great
lengths to acquire
these lung biopsies and they they have
to perform
complex and procedures
that are risky for the patients
these samples also tend to be extremely
small
the biopsy shown here is
a pretty good size
however it contains a pretty small
tumor content which is shown in the
circled area and it's not unusual for us
to get
something like this for molecular
testing in the lab
so the laboratory must produce enough
slides to perform
multiple analyses from the tiny lung
biopsies received
the tests that
need to be performed include a h
e for morphologic assessment to
establish a diagnosis
shown on the upper left
immunohistochemical stains for further
evaluation
and classification and also for a pdl1
assessment this is shown in the upper
right
and just underneath
is a fish analysis
which is used to identify fusions in
amplifications
and to the left of that is
molecular testing which is used to
identify a variety of
genomic alterations
the next logical question for a
laboratorian
is how in the world can we do that much
with so little
when in reality
the tissue that we received is only
enough to make
one h e slide
and often times
this empty block is what we receive in
the molecular lab along with an order
for
molecular testing so if you notice this
this block contains only wax and there's
no tissue left
so in cases like this when where there
is not enough tissue for testing
um it is recommended
that either a repeat biopsy or liquid
testing
be performed this is recommended by both
the
cap islac amp
and nccn guidelines
and on a related note
testing rates for recommended biomarkers
is um not that great even after
you know all this time that we've been
performing them
there was a study presented at asco
last year showing that a group of
patients
1200 patients at five different
hospitals
only about half of them had been tested
for egfr
alk ross1 and pdl1 and the rate is
much lower for the other biomarkers
so the nccn cap is like an amp
clinical practice guidelines call for
the preservation of tissue for molecular
testing
and for pathologists to make a diagnosis
based
on morphology whenever possible
and for the judicious use of
immunohistochemistry
using only p40 and tcf1
immunohistochemicals genes to classify
most nscc cases
and if we follow these recommendations
for
fostering tissue stewardship
it is possible to turn your mole hills
into mountains
and a mole hill of a biopsy into a
mountain of testing results
in our lab we have implemented
the specimen handling protocol shown
here
there is no tissue waste
we start by saving the effacement
shavings in a vial and it's
this little picture of the vial and the
the
shavings are represented by the
um blue lines
on the left um the next uh
couple of sections are used for h e
and two is a
perfect amount is is exactly what is
needed to make the morphologic
assessment
no more than that is necessary the next
set of sections
are for immunohistochemical stains and
pdl1
analysis the following set
is for
molecular testing um and then
followed by fish and we also have
a quality control h e slide
cut just before the molecular
unstained sections so
by following this protocol along with
the clinical practice guidelines for
tissue preservation
we are able to perform all of the
required testing for the majority of the
non-small cell lung cancer biopsies that
are
received in our laboratory
we started testing by ngs in february of
2019 and we started with the
myeloid panel this is a picture of
me and a colleague in my lab looking at
our ngs system
and right next to that is a press
release
announcing that in june of this year
we launched the veterans solid tumor
panel
including the non-small cell lung cancer
veterans mini panel
which includes braf
egfr er
bbb2 teras ahrefs and
nraf pic3a
and akt1 gene
testing we also provide um
alk uh roswan rhett met an amtrak
assessment by fish
in our lab we test all of the biomarkers
that are recommended by
nccn and cap is like an
amp plus some additional biomarkers that
have been designated as
emerging biomarkers
um in general
um ngs can be very helpful because it
can analyze multiple genes
in a single uh run and requires less dna
than is required for a single gene test
so thereby helping you do more with less
this also helps with turnaround times
because you only have to run one test
rather than multiple single gene tests
and so you get faster results
this is a sample pdf report for our ngns
veterans non-small cell lung cancer mini
panel
this is reporting the presence of two
egfr mutations
you can see that bolded right at the
center and then just below that
there is a list of therapies and
available clinical trials for this
patient
um this report highlights the importance
of establishing a testing process to
ensure everyone who needs to be tested
is actually being tested and that their
lab results are available for their
oncologist to use
in making treatment decisions
testing for all biomarkers
improves treatment and overall survival
for these patients
so in conclusion we reviewed the
clinical guideline recommendations
for molecular testing and biopsy tissue
stewardship
and looked at how using conservation
techniques and ngs for molecular testing
can help ensure that there is enough
material available
to perform all of the necessary testing
for
non-small cell lung cancer biopsies
questions
the title of my presentation is
clinical impact of next generation
sequencing testing
a hematopathologist's perspective
my name is megan lim i'm the director of
the division of hematopathology
in the department of pathology at the
university of pennsylvania
in philadelphia
here are my disclosures
the outline of the talk today
um is organized in the following way
i will be introducing very generally the
wh 2017 classification of myeloid
neoplasm
and for this presentation i'm going to
be focusing
specifically on the role of the
hematopathologist
in the diagnostic workup of myeloid
neoplasms
the workup of specimens from patients
with
suspected myeloid neoplasms is very
complicated and has a lot of levels of
complexity which i will focus on
today and also to outline some of the
limitations of the current
workflow that is required in delivering
high quality patient care
or accurate and timely diagnosis sub
classification
treatment and risk stratification
the future perspective perspectives on
how today's research breakthroughs
with the oncoming myeloid assay gx
and the genexis system could
potentially lead to tomorrow's clinical
advancement
specifically for triaging suspected
myeloid malignancies
the learning objectives for this
presentation
are to understand the contribution of
genetic abnormalities in the diagnostic
workup of patients with
suspected myeloid neoplasms to recognize
the limitations of the current
diagnostic workflow in providing timely
integrated genomic results for patients
with suspected myeloid neoplasms
and to become familiar with some of the
clinical scenarios
where rapid integrated next generation
sequencing may
facilitate the diagnostic workup of
patients with
suspected hematologic malignancies
briefly myeloid neoplasms represent
a highly heterogeneous group of diseases
that encompass many different groups of
diseases the diagnostic workup
of patients with these disorders is very
labor intense
and operationally complex and in this
presentation
i will be discussing the
perspective on the clinical impact of
the recent advancements
in ngs testing
this slide demonstrates the complexity
of the current who 2017
classification of myeloid malignancies
um as you can see and many of you are
familiar with
i want you to appreciate that many of
the
specific entities um in
under the rubric of myeloid malignancies
are characterized by a diverse
um group of uh genetic alterations
involving gene rearrangements
mutations copy number variation
and we recognize today that the
contribution of the genetic
abnormalities
play a critical role in the
classification of these myeloid
malignancies
in this slide i will demonstrate that
myeloid neuroplasms are heterogeneous
at many levels clinically
pathologically and genetically
many of these are associated with
characteristic and sometimes
overlapping genetic alterations which
are increasingly playing a critical role
in the diagnosis of classification
treatment and risk stratification of
this diseases
the large groups of myeloid neoplasms
are composed of the chronic myelo
proliferation
neoplasms like cml
polycythemia and others that are defined
by either the dish or able rearrangement
and mutations involving three genes
jack ii calm reticulin and nipple
myelodysplastic syndromes also are
characterized by
mutations in certain genes mds
npn overlapping syndromes also have
uh characteristic gene alterations some
of them
are shared between the myeloproductive
neoplasms
and the myelodysplastic syndromes and
then the group of
acute myeloid leukemias many of which
are characterized by both fusion genes
um as well as mutations
over the last 20 years through
cytogenetic studies we have learned
that specifically in the group of acute
myeloid leukemias
that the cytogenetic abnormalities
are very important in
determining risk stratification and so
we can recognize that there are
favorable risk cytogenetics
intermediate risk amls as well as
unfavorable
risk cytogenetic abnormalities that are
identified in
acute myeloid leukemias with distinct
five-year overall survival rate
moreover in the last 20 years through
many
genomic profiling studies
through whole genome sequencing and as
well as
targeted sequencing studies
have determined that specific mutations
in aml contribute to risk stratification
and i show here a landmark study
published several years ago indicating
that aml's with mutants edp
alpha are have better overall survival
than those with mutant npm-1
without flip3ipd versus the
other genotypes
genetic alterations in aml are also
notable
and important for us to identify in a
very timely manner
because many of them are actionable and
affect treatment decisions that have to
be made
within the first couple of days of the
biopsy
and these have made important
contributions
to improving the patient outcome
specifically rearrangements such as pml
rar
alpha core binding factor
positive amls those that have the beats
or able rearrangements
are amenable for precision therapy
also mutations involving foot 3
as well as idh1 and idh2 also
need to be identified in a relatively
rapid manner
to potentially place patients
on targeted therapy
in certain contexts molecular testing is
dependent
on the core genetic
abnormalities and this requires
of a triaging of a specimen
using the current diagnostic
algorithmic approach for example once we
recognize a
patient with a core binding factor
positive
aml such as
the rungs one rungs one t1 rearrangement
or the core binding factor with the my
h11
then we need to identify those that have
mutations in receptor tyrosine kinases
like kit
and split 3 because those have specific
prognostic information for these
patients
in addition in patients with mixed
phenotype acute leukemia
we also need to specifically assess
these patients for rearrangements
that may provide information about their
nll translocations
another context patients with
aml other than those with confirmed
core binding factor or atl or ml with
mds related cytogenetic abnormalities
need to be identified
because the mutational status of
npm1 dbp alpha and rox1
provide prognostic information for those
patients these are all
provided as examples to highlight the
importance of recognizing certain
disease entities
that would allow us to triage or
algorithmically
test certain disease groups
i've summarized the
content of the complexity of
the current model of delivery of human
pathology patient care
for patients with suspected myeloid
neoplasms
you can see that in the initial
evaluation of
a specimen bone marrow specimen for
patients with
respective mileage neoplasms we may
start
we will start with definitely
blood as well as bone marrow aspirate
a bone marrow core biopsy and sometimes
a crop section
in addition to the morphologic
assessment we
do carry out multiple levels
of analysis usually these are
assessing single analytes
that can start with the enzyme activity
by cytochemistry followed by low
cytometry
based assessment of the antigens
expressed on the cell surface as well as
within the cytoplasm through flow
cytometry and
immunohistochemistry in addition
cytogenetics through karyotyping and
fish studies
are also critical for the workup of many
suspected myeloid neoplasms and then the
molecular diagnostic testing
also requires multiple platforms
to assess usual single analytes
requiring many different platforms such
as rflp
rtpcr as well as next generation
sequencing through either single or
panel-based approaches
you can appreciate that this multi-modal
integrative and iterative process
to establish the diagnosis and identify
risk predictors and identify therapeutic
options
and disease monitoring is quite a
labor-intensive process
that requires a lot of samples material
because of the way it is
carried out currently and so in addition
to the
operational and logistic complexity
there's also the added complexity that
each of these
testing modalities have variable
turnaround times and diagnostic yield
and many all of these contribute to
results where sometimes we will run out
of samples
as well as repeat biopsies from patients
of these precious
material so this is
a slide to demonstrate the multiple
levels of complexity
there we need to discuss the specimen
quality space requirement
time of ordering time of testing time of
result availability
information systems and personnel
coordination
in all of these laboratories to
coordinate the
appropriate and timely testing of all of
these
analytes all of these requires multiple
levels of coordination and result
integration that requires time
and before we can deliver accurate and
timely
information that will impact the
delivery of
precision oncology this is a figure
to demonstrate some of the logistic
complexity
and the complicated workflow many of
these specimens do
come to the clinical lab via
many different routes there is a process
called triaging where we have to assess
the morphologic
um evaluation of the specimens
some of them are then processed in the
surgical pathology
department or division and then
followed by assessment in the
hematopathology
laboratory this highlights that
the logistic complexity may result in
specimen dispersal on dilution through
many different buildings and multiple
labs
results in multiple accession numbers
given to one patient
biopsy material results in
up to eight modalities of testing with
variable specimen needs
with prolonged turnaround times and many
many different hands
that are required to go from
specimen processing to the final result
this is a slide to summarize the
diagnostic work of aml
again um this highlights the different
laboratories and the testing menus and
the
time turnaround time that is uh
expected for each of these analyte
testing
um and in some cases many
uh of these require algorithmic
approaches so example
if you have a aml with a p l r a r
alpha if that is a negative
then we have to solicit additional
uh testing for core binding factor based
on the results of that
we may have to elicit other modalities
of testing
and you can appreciate the complexity
of that is required to successfully
evaluate bone marrow biopsy for patients
with
aml for these cases
so the goals of an optimal diagnostic
workflow for myeloid neoplasms
would be to have a standardized clinical
practice
where you can have streamlined
inter-laboratory logistics
we would like to reduce the time spent
for making the triage
decisions we want to improve the
turnaround time
so that we can initiate the therapy
early
ultimately to reduce the hospital stay
for our patients
and also to reduce the number of repeat
biopsy
and testing that is performed
the uh from the technical perspective
the key disease associated variants
that would be important to test
for patients with suspected myeloid
neoplasms
that would be able to capture
all of the disease entities that i
discussed earlier
including aml mpn mds
these would be should be able to
identify
point mutations insertions deletions
translocations copy number variants as
well as
incorporate gene expression profiles
and be able to identify low frequency
alleles
and importantly for some of the known uh
fusions we would like to identify both
known and
normal variants
so um this is a uh
summary of of the potential
uh implications of having a
rapid ngs testing platform
for hematopathology in
our laboratory we have had the
opportunity
to assess the performance of
the oncoming myeloid assay
which is able to evaluate
all 40 genes that are highly represented
in
myeloid neoplasms that i discussed as
well as
identify 29 fusion driver genes
as well as over 600 fusion isotypes
the advantage of this system is
that it's able to analyze all of these
genetic alterations that are highly
enriched in
myeloproliferative neoplasms
myelodysplastic syndromes
mds npn as well as the acute myeloid
leukemias
using relatively low sample input at
about 20 nanograms
of dna and rna this is a dna
rna-based panel testing it
is a single platform and the results are
provided within 24
to 48 hours
our preliminary data indicates
that this platform could be highly
suitable
for two applications one to be able
to function as a initial molecular
screening assay for us to be able to
triage bone marrows based on flow
cytometry
and the rapid ngf panel
to be able to allocate
the specimen into these four large
the second large application would be in
the diagnostic workup
of acute myeloid leukemias to be able to
identify
both the dna based mutations as well as
the
fusion genes that would be critical
for identifying genetic alterations that
contribute to diagnosis
as well as identify actionable genetic
alterations
within a 24-hour time frame
as well as provide information about
risk
stratification
to summarize we believe that
recent advances in the ngs technology
for oncology research
are providing great promise for future
precision oncology testing
and one example is the oncoming myeloda
gx
on the iron torn genexis system which
enables
robust variant detection and
represents an easy to use workflow
that results or provide results in
as short of a time frame as a single day
and these advancements could represent
future opportunities for
implementing ngs as a first-line
strategy for
triaging suspected myeloid malignancies
thank you and i would be happy to take
questions
and thank you very much to both speakers
for
the presentation so
both of them very interesting two
different topics
but both of them full of details and
very useful information
and now we will move on to the q a
session
we have a few questions coming from the
audience
the first one it's uh it's it's actually
for carmen
and um it's about non-small cell encamps
testing so you certainly showed the
value
of ngs and given the complexity and the
number of biomarkers
that need to be destroyed once there is
no longer discussion
that ngs it should be the preferred
uh method of of uh of testing for this
patient
um however uh uh how do you see
um the let's say the evolving
landscape when it comes to the still
eternal battle between
single gene testing and ngs and i am
especially referring
to the fact that very often as you
mentioned you are starting
from very reduced amount of uh
of samples so very limited amount of
samples do you think ngs can really make
the job
or there is still space for single gene
testing
um well yes i think we've shown that
mgmta has made
all right so you would definitely say
ngs
yeah absolutely absolutely and we've
connected here in
my own laboratory we as we transitioned
[Music]
um so i'll give you an example um um
so initially you could
um
and you know those are two separate
separate things and they require
actually more starting uh dna material
than uh what is required for a single
ngs panel to test everything
um and sometimes we would only have
enough
to to uh run egfr and not enough for
uh buraf um that's that's one example
there
and then also then there's the
turnaround time
um it takes uh and
it's labor intensive so you got to take
that into account as well
so essentially you're
you're taking all the uh the time and
the
labor of um
what you would put into just one test
into ngs
if you're doing a single gene testing
um this could be like multiple days
rather than
um just one day of um
putting this the sample together
for the run so there's a savings
all the way around from dna material
of labor and
turnaround time
so i really don't see this either like
going backwards to
single jeans all right i appreciate i
think you know uh
even though sometimes we give it for
granted that ngs you know
is is the preferred method we still see
actually uh again some kind of traction
and debate
uh about using usage of single gene
testing but i think it was very clear
from your answer
and also from the data that you have
shown that uh
you know the the path it's quite well
defined
in favor of ngs thank you very much
again for answering the question
and now a question for uh dr lin
uh again thank you very much for your uh
presentation
um you have discussed about uh the value
of turnaround time
now i think when it comes to for example
nose muscle and cancer patient
i think it's pretty obvious for the
majority of people
and it immediately comes up to the scene
that
we have to be extremely fast because
very often those patients are in very
late stage of disease
i think sometimes however on the other
hand um
some people are still arguing that maybe
in a mythological disease
turnaround time is not so critical as
for
other you know solid tumor i would be
happy if you could once again reinforce
this concept
about the value of turnaround time if
you believe it
it's actually also a very important
point for a methodological disease
yes i think the uh results also
[Music]
initial
[Music]
definitely
information about potentially putting
patients on clinical trials
and so it's very important to identify
those patients early
before they get treated with their
regular
chemotherapy so
i think current standard is
most of the information that is actually
made available through
genetic testing if we can get them
within
three to four days it would be
have a great clinical impact
all right thank you very much appreciate
a lot your uh your answer
actually we have a second uh question
for you
um this uh this is a little bit
diverging from your uh um
from your uh presentation in a way that
it's asking about
the very fast evo uh
uh growing need of having mrd solution
so the question more specifically it's
about
um how do you see the evolution of using
ngs and specifically ngs for
mrd testing
i think that is a definitely a
important area for future investigations
clearly as as of today
there are not well standardized
approaches
for mrd for
aml definitely there are flow cytometry
based assays as well as
some of the acute lymphoblastic
leukemias they're also
mrd assays but um clearly there's a lot
of
opportunities to investigate ngs based
approaches
if we can get the sensitivity to the
levels that we are able
to obtain that are similar to current uh
methods and that can be standardized
across many laboratories i think those
are the two factors
that would have to be demonstrated for
this type of application to be
widely relevant
i think that that is a very big deal
that
needs to be pursued
all right thank you very much appreciate
a lot your answer again
and with this we actually um conclude
this q a section
once again thank you very much to
speaker for their presentation also
thank you very much for taking the time
for uh having answered to our question
and now we will have a break um of about
20 minutes so we will be back here for
the second part of these
events and for uh another two uh
presentation
once again thank you very much speakers
thank you very much uh to the audience
for being with us
uh a pleasure have a uh uh uh
join me later please
you